[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con el día de
hoy hablaremos sobre digitalización de
la banca con rubén salazar genovés él es
vicepresidente senior de productos de
innovación para visas para américa
latina y el caribe
bienvenido a france 24 y quiero comenzar
preguntándole la pandemia de kobe 19
acelero los procesos de digitalización a
nivel mundial qué retos supone esto para
la banca
hace rangel a lo que hemos visto es una
gran dependencia de los consumidores de
utilizar más tecnología para comunicarse
con sus bancos y poder realizar las
transacciones que tradicionalmente
ejecutaban por medio de una visita a una
sucursal o por medio de una llamada
ahora los servicios que la banca presta
tienen que caber en un teléfono móvil y
entonces esto pone en reto una serie de
inversiones que los bancos tienen que
hacer para poder acomodarse a estas
nuevas realidades bueno y de qué manera
se traduce en esas nuevas realidades
estos retos en oportunidades de
innovaciones y de crecimiento como
podría verse el impacto para el usuario
común
bueno en realidad las condiciones para
que una banca digital exista en
latinoamérica ya están dadas más del 70%
de los consumidores ya tienen una
terminal inteligente o un portátil
inteligente en sus en sus manos y más
del 60% de los consumidores a través de
toda latinoamérica ya tienen acceso a
internet entonces
la banca puede aprovechar esta capacidad
instalada para proveer mejores servicios
y mejores experiencias para que los
usuarios puedan comunicarse y realizar
las transacciones sin necesidad de ir en
un momento físico a resolver por su
problema en la banca no
brasil por ejemplo más del 60% de las
transacciones que vemos ocurren de
manera digital
y eso ahorra tiempo el consumidor le
permite obtener los servicios que
tradicionalmente tiene que obtenerlo por
una visita física bueno rubén y entonces
cuáles son las implicaciones para la
evolución y para el futuro de los medios
de pago
pero las implicaciones es que cada vez
estamos viendo la necesidad de aumentar
la digital la inclusión digital de los
consumidores a través de latinoamérica
tradicionalmente la industria de pagos
dependía de la presencia de un datáfono
de un ps para poder realizar la compra
es decir para poder conectar a
consumidores y a comercios necesitábamos
un cable y una estructura física ahora a
través de teléfonos móviles podemos
aumentar la participación de más y más
comercios y más consumidores la
oportunidad para latinoamérica es grande
más del 70% de las transacciones ocurren
en casa y hay más de 50 millones basado
en nuestros propios estimados hay más de
50 millones de pequeños comercios que
necesitan esta conectividad para
participar en una economía digital por
el otro lado hay más de 200 millones de
individuos en latinoamérica que no
tienen acceso a banco entonces al
utilizar techno
nosotros podemos alcanzar a más y más
consumidores y más comercios
bueno mientras que avance ese proceso de
digitalización le pregunto si va a
cambiar el rol de los bancos por ejemplo
las sucursales físicas dejarían de ser
necesarias y otro tema es que con la
llegada de la pandemia también se han
congestionado tanto las líneas para
hacer uso de los medios digitales que
este es otro reto que tienen este es un
reto importantísimo a los bancos ángeles
de poder
y resolver el mejor banco va a ser un
banco que se maneja en un canal y da de
decir que no importa el canal el que el
cliente escoja para interactuar con el
banco el banco está listo para proveer
una experiencia al usuario sin sin
fricción como consumidor yo debería
poder escoger hacer mis transacciones en
la web hacerlas a través de un teléfono
o visitar la sucursal o llamar no
entonces no importa el canal de donde el
consumidor quiera interactuar con su
banco el banco tiene que tener una
tecnología que le permita dar este tipo
de omni calidad para el consumidor es el
mayor reto saber poder poder interactuar
en múltiples canales con el cliente
rubén gracias por estar con nosotros y
se nos queda por fuera un tema que nos
queda para la reflexión a todos y es el
problema que representaría la inclusión
dentro de estos procesos digitales
gracias a ustedes por estar con nosotros
sigan en france24
[Música]